Transcriber: gaith Takrity
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
رسمت هذه اللوحة في عام 1976،
وكان عمري حينها 17 سنة.
كما ترون، تحتوي على سفن
تصارع الأمواج والعواصف.
تحكي هذه السفن قصة الرحالة البرتغالي
واسمه “بارثولوميو دياز“،
الذي حاول أن يلتف حول رأس الرجاء الصالح
في عام 1487 بهدف أن يصل إلى الهند.
بسبب المخاطر، لم يستطع أن يكمل المشوار
وعاد إلى بلده البرتغال.
لكنه مهد الطريق لرحالة
برتغالي آخر هو “فاسكو دي جاما“،
الذي التف حول هذا المكان في عام 1498،
ووصل الى الهند، وبهذا غيّر مجرى التاريخ.
ما أعجبني في هذه القصة هو الشغف
والصبر والتحدي الذي تمثله.
وإلى حدٍ ما وجدت أن هناك تشابه بين هذه
القصة وبين قصتي أنا في العمارة، في مهنتي،
التي كان فيها تحديات كبيره.
واستطعت أن أتجاوز هذه الصعاب بفضل الله،
وبفضل أهلي والمخلصين حولي،
وبفضل الشغف والحب لمهنة العمارة،
والإصرار والصبر لتحقيق الأهداف.
بدأت قصتي مع العمارة قبل أن أدرسها.
بدأت منذ نشأتي في الكويت،
حيث كانت مدينة قديمة.
وبدأت بحلول سنوات الستينيات والسبعينيات
من القرن العشرين تتحول بسرعة،
من مدينة بنيانها من الطين وطرقها ضيقة،
إلى مدينة حديثة شوارعها عريضة وخرسانية.
فغذّى لديّ هذا الشيء حب العمارة.
ومن خلال زياراتي مع أهلي في تلك الفترة،
في سنوات الستينيات والسبعينيات،
إلى المدن التاريخية العريقة
في المشرق العربي،
مثل بغداد وعمّان والقدس ودمشق،
غذّى ذلك أيضًا حب وشغف للعمارة.
وأذكر أنني كنتُ أجمع طوابع الرسائل
التي كان يرسلها إخوتي الذين يدرسون في مصر،
وكانت تلفت انتباهي الطوابع التي عليها
المآثر والمباني التاريخية في القاهرة.
مما جعلتني أيضًا أحب العمارة.
وأذكر أن صديقًا مصريًا لي
أهداني كتابًا اسمه “القاهرة في ألف عام“،
وكانت الصور التي تحتويه
بمثابة كنز مبهر بالنسبة لي.
وعندما قررت أن أذهب إلى الجامعة
بعد التوجيهي في عام 1977،
كان من الممكن أن أدرس في جامعة الكويت،
وأكون مع أهلي و أصحابي في المدرسة.
وكنت أستطيع أن أختار أي تخصص أريده
لأنني كنت من العشرة الأوائل.
لكن للأسف لم يكن هناك تخصص
عمارة  في جامعة الكويت حينها.
فكان ذلك أول تحدٍ بالنسبة لي
حيث كنتُ مضطرًا أن أدرس خارج البلاد.
وكان هدفي الأول هو الذهاب إلى القاهرة،
وكانت رغبتي شديدة بالذهاب إليها.
ولكن شاءت الأقدار والظروف
أن تمنعني من الذهاب إلى القاهرة،
وكان البديل الثاني بالنسبة لي هو بريطانيا.
وبصدفة عجيبة جدًا، وجدت نفسي في بلدة صغيرة
بجانب لندن اسمها “سويندن“،
وكنت مضطرًا لإعادة التوجيهي مرة أخرى،
وكان شرط دخول الطالب الجامعات البريطانية،
حصول الطالب على مستويات متقدمة “أ”،
أو ما يعرف بشهادة التعليم العام/ “GCE”،
طبعًا، كان دراسة سنتين كاملتين مضيعة وقت
بالنسبة لي خاصة أنني درستُ ذلك من قبل.
فذهبت إلى الإدارة وقلت لهم أنني أريد
المجازفة بأن أدرس السنتين بسنة واحدة فقط.
طبعًا، لم يكن هذا الأمر سهلاً،
إلا أنني تحديته.
وفعلًا،
بعد سنة وجدتُ نفسي في “مانشستر“،
وهي واحدة من أهم الجامعات البريطانية،
ويمكن أن تكون من أهم الجامعات
في كل أرجاء العالم.
وفي الحقيقة وجودي في “مانشستر”
لم يمنعني من التفكير بالقاهرة.
ومحبتي للعمارة العربية والإسلامية
دفعتني عندما حان وقت موضوع مشروع التخرج
في عام 1983 أن أختار القاهرة
كمكان للقيام بهذا المشروع.
و كان هناك اعتراض لِمَ لا أكون
مع زملائي في بريطانيا،
حيث يكون مشروع التخرج أسهل بالنسبة إليهم.
لكنني اخترت الطريق الأصعب.
ذهبت إلى القاهرة حتى أنني عندما أخترتها،
اخترتُ أصعب مكان فيها،
الذي هو قلب القاهرة التاريخي،
والذي يحتوي على كل الطبقات من التاريخ،
وفيه مشاكل حضرية ومشاكل بيئية.
اخترت هذا المكان وبدأت هذه الرحلة
حيث قمتُ بزيارة شيخ المعماريين العرب
الذي هو حسن فتحي.
وأذكر نصيحته لغاية الاّن بأنه،
“يجب على المعماري أن يحترم التراث
والمكان الذي يقتحمه“.
لذلك، بدأت هذه الرحلة بقناعة،
أن المكان ليس عمارات عظيمة فقط،
إنما المكان هو ناس،
المكان هو ثقافة، والمكان هو مجتمع.
وبالتأكيد، فإن هؤلاء الناس ضمن هذا المكان.
وكنتُ حينها أقوم بالكثير من المخططات،
وكان توثيق المكان جزءًا
من رحلتي المعمارية،
وكان عليّ إيصاله إلى أساتذتي
في “مانشستر“، وأن يكون واضحًا
من خلال المخططات والتحليلات واللقاءات.
وكان نتيجة ذلك كله مشروع التخرج
الذي شكّل توجهاتي المعمارية لغاية الاَن.
وكان المشروع حول تطوير حي الحسين،
المنطقة ما بين الأزهر والحسين،
وهي منطقة حيوية جدًا
في القاهرة ويعرفها الجميع.
والحمد لله لاقَ المشروع تقديرًا عاليًا
من الجمعية الملكية للمعماريين البريطانيين،
ومن جمعية المعماريين في “مانشستر“،
ومن جامعة “مانشستر” نفسها.
فكان هذا دافعًا قويًا بالنسبة لي
لأبدأ حياتي المهنية،
بنفس الشغف وروح التحدي.
كانت هذه فرصة لأعود إلى الكويت،
وقمتُ بالعمل بأكبر مكتب في الكويت
يدعى مكتب المهندس الكويتي.
وكنت محظوظًا لأنه من أوائل المشاريع
التي  اشتغلتُ عليها،
كان إعادة إحياء المنطقة التي هُدمت
في الخمسينيات والستينيات
التي هي الكويت القديمة
واسم هذه المنطقة شرق السيف.
فكان المشروع هو إعادة إحياء
وتطوير لهذه المنطقة.
وواحد من أهم المشاريع التي اشتغلتُ عليها
في تلك المرحلة أيضًا،
كان مبرّة صباح السالم،
وكان مشروعًا خيريًا،
من خلاله حاولتُ تطوير العمارة التراثية،
ليصبح لها صفة معاصرة
تنسجمُ مع بيئتنا وزماننا اليوم.
لكن التحدي الذي كان أمامي هنا
هو أن التوجهات  السائدة في العمارة،
كانت لا تزال حداثية.
وكان المكتب نفسه يقوم بتصميم
مباني أبراج وخرسانة وزجاج،
وأنا كنت أغرد خارج السرب،
كنتُ أؤسّـس شيئًا جديدًا من منظوري أنا،
بأن أربط بين الماضي بالحاضر
بالمستقبل من خلال العمارة.
لكن هذه التجربة، للأسف،
لم أستطع أن أكملها بسبب الظروف القاسية
التي كانت في الكويت عام 1990،
التي قلبت كل الموازين،
وجعلتني أعود لنقطة الصفر.
تركت الكويت وذهبت الى عمّان،
وأثناء فترة قصيرة وجدتُ نفسي في ظل
ظروف صعبة ولا تزال صعبة للغاية،
ولكي أستطيع أن أحقق طموحاتي وأكمل مسيرتي،
كان لزامًا عليّ أن أهاجر،
وهاجرتُ إلى أمريكا حتى أجد فرصًا أفضل.
وفي أمريكا،
اخترتُ أيضًا تحديًا كبيرًا
وهو أنني أردتُ التقديم
إلى أهم جامعة في العالم في مجال العمارة
وهي جامعة ماساتشوستس للتقينة/ إم آي تي.
وكان ذلك أيضًا تحديًا كبيرًا،
حيث كنتُ قد قدمت لها من عشر سنين وتم رفضي.
لم يكن الموضوع سهلًا،
لكن الحمد لله عندما تم قبولي
شعرت أن الدنيا بدأت تبتسم لي من جديد.
وكان كل ذلك في فترة مدتها أقل من عام
منذ خروجي من الكويت.
لكن هل انتهت هذه التحديات؟
لا، لماذا؟ لأنني بدأت أشعر بالغربة،
وبدأت أشعر بحنين جارف للمنطقة العربية
لا سيما الكويت، لكن لم تسمح الظروف
في الكويت سياسيًا من العودة إليها،
مثلما منعتني السياسة
من الذهاب إلى القاهرة.
لكنني مؤمن،
على الرغم من سهولة تواجدي في أمريكا،
ووجود فرص عمل كثيرة فيها
خصوصًا بعد هذا الإنجاز.
لكنني مؤمن، ولا زلت مؤمنًا
أنه يجب أن أكمل مسيرتي،
ومشوار حياتي في العالم العربي.
لذلك فعلت كما فعل طارق بن زياد،
قلتُ سأحرق السفن، طبعًا هذه أسطورة.
لكن أريد العودة إلى العالم العربي،
ولا أريد العودة إلى أي مكان اَخر مرة أخرى.
وجدت نفسي في عمّان،
عمّان التي بدأت فيها مشواري من سنة 1993
وإلى غاية الآن أنا موجود معكم.
كان المشوار طويلًا؛
درستُ في جامعات وعملتُ في مكاتب كبيرة،
ومكاتب صغيرة ومكاتب محلية ومكاتب أجنبية،
واستقريت هنا وبدأت أفكر
كيف من الممكن بطريقة أو بأخرى
أستطيع العودة إلى الكويت.
استطعت العودة إلى الكويت
من خلال بعض المشاريع التي قمنا بها،
وعرفتُ أيضًا كيفية تحقيق الأفكار
التي بدأت التفكير فيها بالثمانينيات.
لكن، كنت قد ركزتُ في هذه المشاريع
على علاقة الإنسان بالطبيعة،
وعلاقتنا بالماضي والحاضر والمستقبل.
فهذه المشاريع التي اشتغلنا عليها
هي التي تعزز هذه العلاقات.
والحقيقة أنه كانت هناك مشاريع كبيرة أيضًا.
وحازت هذه المشاريع، مثل مدينة الفحيحيل،
في تلك الفترة على تقدير عالٍ جدًا وجوائز،
واعتبر هذا المشروع واحدًا من أهم المشاريع،
وحاز على جائزة كبيرة على مستوى العالم،
من المجلس العالمي لمراكز التسوق.
وتكللت هذه الفترة بأنني أخذت  جائزة
من منظمة المدن العربية،
جائزة المعماري العربي في عام 2008.
كانت هذه الجائزة عن مجمل الأعمال
التي وصلت لها في تلك الفترة.
لكنها تزامنت مع أزمات؛
الأزمة الاقتصادية العالمية في ذلك الوقت
التي هزت كل المنطقة،
وبالتأكيد أثرت على قطاع الأعمال
والبناء والعمارة.
لكنني أقول أنه في رحم
هذه الأزمات تولد الفرص،
وفي هذه اللحظة قررت
أن أتخذ أجرأ قرار في حياتي،
وهو أن أفتح مكتبي الهندسي.
وكنت في بداية العقد السادس من عمري.
في هذا المكان، أستطيع أن أعبر عن طموحاتي
والأفكار التي طورتها خلال السنوات الطويلة.
وبدأت العمل مع فريقي في أماكن مختلفة،
مثلاً البنك الأهلي في عُمان،
ودرب المشاعر في مكة المكرمة في السعودية،
قمنا بعدة مشاريع في الشارقة،
الذي يعرف حديقة المجاز،
وقلب الشارقة والمنطقة التراثية حيث قمنا
أيضًا بإعادة إحيائها وعمل خطة أساسية لها.
وكان هناك أيضَا
في إمارة الشارقة منتجعًا كبيرًا
على البحر في منطقة تسمى كلباء.
ومنتجع آخر في وسط الصحراء،
بمعنى كان هناك تنوع كبير.
وهذا التنوع في الحقيقة امتد
حتى كان لنا في الكويت مشاريع
في هذا المكان مثل هذا المجمع السكني
الذي كان التركيز فيه على كيفية
علاقة الإنسان بالطبيعة
والعمارة بكل هذه الظروف.
حتى استطعنا أن نقوم بعمل مشروع في أمريكا،
ومحور هذا المشروع هو مادة الأطروحة
لرسالة الماجستير التي عملتها في إم آي تي؛
التي كانت تتحدث عن المراكز الإسلامية،
وكان المشروع مركزًا إسلاميًا
في مدينة “كولورادو سبرينغز“.
ليست العمارة مخططات
وواجهات فقط، العمارة مسؤولية:
“لأننا نحن كمعماريين،
يوجد لنا دور كبير في التأثير بشكل جوهري
على حياة الناس وطريقة حياتهم ومعيشتهم،
وكيف يتعاملوا ويتفاعلوا
مع العالم كله الذي يعيشون فيه“.
وأقول أن الجائزة الأكبر في كل هذا
هي كيف نستطيع أن نسعد الناس.
وهذه السعادة تنعكس علينا
عندما نُسعدهم لأننا نفرح بإنجازاتنا
حيث استطعنا أن نقدم الشيء
الذي هم يبحثون عنه .
أنا اليوم محاط في مكتبي
بمجموعة كبيرة من المعماريين
الذين بدأوا هذا المشوار معي؛
منهم أناس تركوا ومنهم موجودون.
لكن هدفي أن أنقل لهم
كل هذه الخبرات وهذه التجارب
التي مررتُ بها، والعلم على مدار 40
أو 45 سنة التي مضت.
ولوحة دياز لا تزال موجودة
عندي في المكتب أحتفظ فيها،
وأعتبر وكأني كنت أستشرفُ المستقبل
عندما رسمتها قبل 46 سنة،
لم يقدر دياز أن يكمل المشوار،
لكنه فتح الطريق،
ومهد الطريق لغيره لكي يُكملوا.
فأنا على الأقل، أرجو أن أكون -
سببًا في أن غيري، يوم من الأيام،
يقدر أن يكمل المشوار على المنهج
الذي بدأته ويحقق إنجازات أكبر
ويصل إلى قمم أعلى.
ولا تزال نفس الصعاب موجودة حولنا،
والرجوع الذي اضطر له دياز وحدث معه،
ليس من لغتي التي أفكر بها،
إنما أنا هنا مثل طارق بن زياد،
طارق بن زياد الذي وضع أمامه هدف،
وأصر على تحقيقه.
ولسان حالي يقول:
“تقصد إلى قمم الأشياء تدركها،
تجري الرياح كما أرادت لها سفن
نحن الرياح ونحن البحر والسفن“.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)